you okay I'm sorry what's going on guys
nothing I just got I I just want to go
back to I want to go to bed and that's
it that's it what was your name Ashley
Thomas Ashley
Thomas do you work at Clayton's or no I
was there for a drink then he came in
and the bartender who favors me but
doesn't like him gave him a free drink
but then she started saying
talking about him and then was still
like favoring him I was like okay
whatever I said nothing and then some
girl came up and pushed me grabbed me by
my neck so like she got an argument with
the bartender some lady at the bar never
get AR she was walking out trying to
find her code to leave the
bar earlier the the bigger girl grab DED
her by her neck threw her against the
wall by the D box
and you know yelling match ensued and I
dragged her out of the bar yeah just
happened and I just want to go back to
where I sleep where do you live at I'm
currently staying staying at an Airbnb
on uh East Illinois Avenue East Illinois
Avenue did you just walk over here then
yes Goa do you you guys just have IDs on
you and I'll get out of here I don't
have Hood I I don't have a like I don't
have a valid ID valid resid any kind of
ID yes some sort of
yeah here's
my that's
perfect and then some girl I don't even
know came out of nowhere grabbed me by
my neck threw me up against the wall
like some fat bitch she had to be 250 at
least but like that's okay right no
absolutely not did she already leave
okay but would I call the Cs no no I'm
okay I could handle that I I I could
deal that I am okay I've been through
worse like I'm good do you need an
ambulance or anything hell no I'm just
asking just
Mak all right you you're good to go
ahead and walk home if you want are you
sure she was accused of slapping one
officer and Kicking another police
officer during the arresting process let
C okay are you going to be all right all
right okay perfect thank
you we're
good you're I'm going to take you to the
ground no stop give me your hands stop
resisting no give me your hand stop
resisting give me your hand stop
resisting why why because
I did not SL did I slap you your face
yeah okay bye everything I pay for bye
leave me
alone it's not fair stop
stop bye have fun pay
for I want him out of the place that I
live in I want him out now worry about
can you do that now I want you to do
that now please please broke the sign no
no please wait wait what I yeah because
I'm pissed I watch you break the because
I'm you
know it's soir if you take me to
jail I'm done I'm done I'm I'm
going it's a lighter it's a
lighter you take me to jail done yeah
sotic battery yep I for battery right
because I've been up for the past year
you guys about
it about
it okay Ashley okay Ashley right cuz
I've been strangled and I've had black
eyes you guys just it
right you the car thanks a lot you
yourself no
the apartment
myop if you ever
Ashley you're going to break the window
and that's a felony so
stop Sarah just
take you
want jail and then we'll
come on Ashley no step out of the car no
step out of the car I'm going to take
you out of the car why is there four
five four five people out here to get
Ashley last morning step out of the car
I'll step out step out ask me asley
please step out of the car Ashley come
on please just not be here I don't need
to be
here I don't need this this is not fair
and where's my person I've got your
person where's my person want go home I
want
everybody like why are you handing me
I'm going to walk in my own place
if you walk if you push me that way
I'm stand up um I can't I can't if you
push me yeah yeah yeah no out of my
faceit where where body if you touch me
again any more aggressively I'm going to
up I swear to God you're not a bad ass
you really H for t tiit for
T sit up for a wrong with
you fig we got to go up there if you
feel that way you let the doctor know
they will probably discharge you
with won't better want to hurt I won't
hurt myself I don't I want to go back
home I want to go home
seriously like I take on that who need
more help than I do and then I drink and
then it all falls on of me like I was at
the bar and like I paid for I I paid for
everything for this guy he got a free
drink and got a free drink and another
free drink and this girl's known me
she's never known him and she was so
nice to him and he was so nice to her
and it's like and then this fat comes at
me and strangles she strangles me it's
okay I here I'm sitting here all right
so like I I can I can actually like say
I don't want to be here like I'm My Own
human you got to be here because you
said you're going to kill yourself okay
well it shouldn't be too long because
like here I am and this one is like your
sleeves inside out on that one waiting
at no no no no no because the no because
I don't give with the the blood test
shows I want to go sit down I have a
question though I have a question and I
want to ask what an RN or a doctor what
they took blood for I want to know you
can talk to them no when they don't walk
past I want to know now ask them go go
ask them sit down no no do me a favor
and go ask them they
sit sit down no I'm not going to don't
talk to me you want me to put you back
in cuffs no and I don't want you do
you're not going to back off no and
don't touch me back off and don't touch
me don't put your hands in my face you
just touch my you just touch me you just
touch me I want to know why I'm standing
here waiting for what what result she
just touched me first okay so can you
ask no I didn't I stood right here and I
said I want to know what I'm waiting for
you're waiting on the blood results I'm
not Amber I'm Ashley so what what I want
to go they had a traa from a traffic
that's very sad this what's taking so
long that's that's saddening chill I'll
leave and they can deal with all all
their attention could be diverted on
that I want to go I am not a trauma we
will I'm not a trauma I want to leave
can you please go like inquire about
when the I can get out of here the more
you ask the more if you chill out I'll
talk to about chilling out it's like a
like I'm not a mental patient like get
me the out of here I want to
go he's mad at you why not mad at you no
like you just assume that what's going
on you assume that I said I want out of
here okay I understand but we're waiting
for labs to come back do make them
faster and I'm not dying so let me go so
here's my opinion would you rather sit
in this comfy bed then go to jail I'm
going to go to jail regardless let me
get it over with please and I'll bond
out like I don't care please take me
again I have no choice I have to wait
for I I don't have a choice okay so
screaming and yelling and I'm not
screaming I'm just asking her she's not
giving me a straight answer she I can
hear you from all the way down here I
have kids I right but I have children
which you said you have children I have
children here and they can hear you
screaming your children can hear you
screaming the children that are here can
hear you screaming and yelling okay so
get me out of here is the best thing
take me to jail when I have the result
can you take me to jail wait what are we
waiting on what results are going to
your labs to come back tell us that
you're not sick what is what what kind
of sickness is there that's you could
have urinary tract infection you could
have I do have I always have okay so
nothing I'm going to argue with is going
to change my mind so I need you to sit
down and stand here cuz I'm very
impatient so either is shoot me in the
ass with the Adan or something like I'm
not doing that I'm sorry I don't know I
I didn't I didn't bring you here I
didn't want to be here either okay well
I didn't cause you to be here so you I
didn't cause me either like but there's
a lot of abusive I understand that but
right now you're being loud and you're
being disruptive to the entire e so just
sit down and please
quiet okay need my first right now don't
touch me don't touch me again I want to
leave and don't touch me again before I
jack you in the face you're not being
very fair if you put your hands on me I
have every right to put my hands on you
don't touch me and think I ain't going
to fucking touch your back as weird as
fuck are you threatening a public off
I'm not I'm not threatening you you just
touched me with a felony no I don't you
touched me why do you think I can't
touch
I want my purse and my purse has my
personal possessions in it I'm
discharging you okay can you please
thank you let me get your papk person
ever thank you yep thank you that's all
I wanted yeah and don't ever touch me
I'm going to put cups on you in about
cuz if I can touch you if I can touch
you and you're going to complain about
it then you there where's the where's
the
equality all right yeah I'm good I'm
done here we go again
y
here
I'm not taking from you it's all
equality right
equality where's my purse at though in
the car get in the car where is it
though it's in the car in the front it's
in the front okay yeah I don't want to
want to be
TCH there is out me
okay
I'm sorry you're going to have to well
why why is that why is that can you give
me a second and quit screaming at me I'm
talking to you in a call I'm not not
screaming at you I'm asking you why is
that because birth ELO statute where
you're being charged because no bond it
has to be set by a
judge what why for what like what
domestic battery is no bom what cuz I
smack in the face cuz he deserved it
who oh my
god
wow I can't get out I to see a Dr why do
I have to see a Dr this morning it's
already 3:00 in the morning I know I
that I want to go have a cigarette I
want to go to bed I want this that the
other thing I want to go to bed I want
to go to bed I don't I don't disrup
nobody I want to go to bed you can right
now but I don't want to hang out with
inmates here I don't want to be in jail
nobody
does I'm just I'm I'm just saying
that you don't have very long to to wait
no what did I do though domestic
battery can I see can I see the camera I
don't believe it until I see the camera
I wasn't there I see it who's got it
who's got it you got it got it you got
ITP cour for subpoena okay no that's not
a cour for I want to see it now cuz you
could say you could say I didn't now but
who cares sometimes the guy needs a a
slap in the face sometimes is life in
the face like show me that something
happened I recall it like let me go I
live right there if you want your phone
calls I got a picture for you I got to
PR you and I'm getting out and I'm going
to pay my way out you're not leaving
till you get so how is that true though
because I know that can get like pulled
over what $10,000 worth of cocaine and
they like got on an ibon or what you
call your lawyer he will tell you no
then I I'll just I'm going to get out
now you're not leaving now yes I am I my
way out saying this I told you there's
no bond it's set by the statue you can
no it's not what because I hit a in the
face cuz he deserved it I'm sorry if
you've had domestic battery issues
that's on you why you didn't call police
no I no because somebody seen it who
called one of you probably seen it you
oh you seen it oh yeah I guess for the
boy so anyway do you want to harm
yourself at all no I don't I want to
harm like somebody if they don't want me
yeah you're just getting ready to say if
I can get if I can go to jail and get
and bond myself out drinking and driving
whether that be killing myself or
somebody else but yet I snack a white
bit like a in the face like how does
that make sense that's rules that that
doesn't even make any we got to go by
like I went out on the road wasted
drinking and I could have killed five a
family of five okay this is this is way
it's going to go nope not staying here
you have to stay here not and either we
can put you in this in in your jail un I
or you can put yourself in okay so I
want to see the the video we don't have
the
video who had the video the me smack of
somebody who had the video we watched
you do it who who you w so let me see
you had the body came on you when you
when it happened so where is it all
right where is it Ashley I'm calling my
I'm calling my wire give me my phone I
got my lawyer going to get a callone
process I not going be on that door and
the lawyer's going to tell you the same
thing you got to stay no he's going to
say Ashley
get
everybody and nobody's taking a picture
of me you're not you're not you're not
you're not nobody's taking a picture of
me okay you get that it's going to
happen one way not it's not going to
well to me it's not going to cuz I'm not
going to consent to it
and so like when I want my lawyer's
number I want it now so give me my phone
right now and I'm going to call him
right now so how about that that's fine
that's fine so give me my phone now calm
down I'm calm down give me my phone
you're not calm I'm calm and you're not
okay so like what do you want me to do
I'm going to give you a piece of paper
in your phone five or six and like some
when you was little I don't know sorry
don't blame me blame whoever just you
can't call anybody on it just
to get see this
is they want my purse they want
everything in it and it doesn't give you
permission here
I'm then give me then let me ready can
you stop no you stop stop put the phone
pH back why would you touch me you
bit your
fucking stop stop
give me your arm give me your arm give
me your
arm guys Cuts y stop squeezing my finger
okay she's got my clo it's
okay and now you just R now she kicked
me too because you took me down
get the in the
face get away from me you don't just go
punching cops in the face I just
touching
you and you touch me
retarded oh she's done what cuz you're
pirate away for me leave me the alone
NOP I'm laying right here I'll sleep
right here I'm
good phone what's up your phone touch me
don't do not touch me up no I can get
myself I can get myself up I don't need
help if you ever touch me
again if you touch me again I'm going to
hurt you
you no he's a I want out I can't oh wait
wait wait till he gets fired done
for done
go no don't want to leave don't talk
me wait till I start
screaming leave me why you sitting on
there leave me
alone leave me the
alone get me out of
here you and your
there me here give
me